please welcome chef lenny the bearded
dragon and his culinary partner
and owner valerie musser
hey thank you so much for coming
i love it thanks for having us oh
chef lenny how did this cookbook come
about jeremy wants to know
well so lenny was building a lot of
traction
on instagram people just loved all the
food posts that we did
we were doing national day calendar post
you know everything's like national
pretzel day or national cake day or
all of these food things that are out
there and people just
they really love those so we decided to
uh
to put together a cookbook with with
lenny as the chef
because there were no at the time
until jeremy came along lizard chefs so
it's perfect
well chef lenny i want to ask you
what we're making today today we're
going to make ma's famous carrot cake
and i'm ma and now you get to be ma too
okay
what do we do first so first step is to
grade some carrots we're just going to
grate some here
you should have all your stuff
now do you wrap we're not going to grate
all of them
we need three cups for this recipe so
that's that's quite a bit of green
okay perfect so that's like the sexy
sample then we'll move this away
exactly and then we have
um three cups of carrots right here
we do so just take your carrots and add
it
right to your wet ingredients which you
should have in a bowl
and that has the pecans and the eggs and
the sugars
and the salt and just dump it in this is
just that simple
and then stir it up
okay so i've got all my wet ingredients
together then you're good
we just move on to the next step here
we're going to add the dry with those
dry ingredients
right on top which is our flour cinnamon
baking powder
baking soda just dump it in nothing
fancy here
and stir it up we just want it to
be mixed together but not over mixed
like pancakes just just like pancakes or
anything with
baking powder it seems like you know you
need to be folded in
okay i'm good to go next okay now we
pour this into our
pans yep right into your prepared pans
there
okay perfect jeremy are you listening
and lenny
what are your thoughts it's just making
sure i don't screw it up
chef lenny judging my moves
chef lenny what's your favorite color my
favorite color is yellow
really what sign are you lenny
i'm a pisces
lenny do you think i'm nuts um
yep that's right okay so now we put the
pans in the oven
we do we just put them in the oven bake
them at 325 degrees for 40 to 45 minutes
and then you're good to go and since you
know we don't have
a ton of time on our hands we've got our
finished
masterpieces
with a cream cheese frosting which is
just cream cheese sugar
oil vanilla and salt so now we have the
cake
and we're going to decorate it with
edible flowers
we are so um okay here we go
am i yeah i just decorate however i want
or however
however you want sometimes if i make
like i was you know and i am not a
professional cake baker
however i love cake and you know if you
just arrange it
in a way that i don't know your little
flowers cascade down
so again you have a little spring cake
it's just
the flowers make it so much
happier this is so beautiful by the way
like if i got this at a fancy bakery i
would not
question it whatsoever no you'd be like
that is legit
jeremy lenny what do you think i think
it's lovely
oh thank you lenny and
jeremy all right let's um i'm gonna
taste this now i'm just going right
into the cake just
here we go here we go here we go jeremy
ready i'm just gonna eat it with my
hands oh my god
i swear to god i could eat this like
i do eat this like three or four times a
year and it never gets old
oh valerie it's a cake
it's a spring cake oh god
that is so incredible
bionic stuff lenny are so talented
we're we're a good team valerie and chef
lenny
thank you so much for coming on the
lovely show valerie and chef lenny go to
the drewbryme.com for the full recipe
you